[Music]
well it's October the second we are a
few days into our calving season and we
have a few calves on the ground but it's
also time for us to finish up our hay
season for the year so I'm standing in
front of one of our smaller fields that
my husband is just started cutting it
does not look great even though we do
have a great stand of Johnson grass but
we need to clean these fields up and get
done so I want to take you to the
process of how we cut Ted rake and
bel-air Hey
here we go and that's my boy
cutting hay for the very first time
riding with its dad awesome go Wesley go
and this is the good stuff y'all this is
the good stuff I always loved the way
hey looks
first cut
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm just gonna follow that little blue
tractor and show you some setting so we
used to use the big tractor but he
acquired this little tractor last year
and it works perfect for this
[Music]
so first three days of its life its
first three days of life
if this camp is not nursing its laying
under this tractor and I really hate to
break its little heart but I'm about to
have to go rake and I'm gonna need my
tractor back little buddy so the time
has come for the best most important
part of the hay making process which is
raking and bailing raking because it's
my job and because if you don't rake
right then you don't have good bales and
in the end that's like the most
important thing so the pressures on
today my rod has new bigger wider tires
I haven't driven it yet and the pressure
is on because I'm not going to be able
to turn as tight as I usually do and
sometimes I've been known to turn too
tight anyway and you know like sometimes
blow hoses and like hit the rake and
stuff so today I can't do that I'm gonna
royally mess something up so here's
hoping that I don't really mess
something up we'll see going back home
because I forgot the radios
really have you ever seen
such a fine truck as this
pretty awesome it's even got the whole
heart beat the whole heartbeat of
America thing going on yep radios and
tea we can now go bill hey sorry Bonnie
you gotta stay here like the skies
clouding up which is not good for making
hay and I think a little bit thinks
there's a storm coming
anyway mm here we go as I bought my hand
in a while hopefully I remember how
first things first err on
really hot today y'all
my turn
but I didn't run into my new tires
man
hi
tractor
straight
but important thing to be
[Music]
I hope you hear me
I think I'll just go out right here he
taught me to go to the next field
okay
this is not this is not my favorite
family so every farm around here stayin
after somebody like the person we
brought in from this is a little farm
this is a little big plan that we don't
she just lets take Kate off of it but I
have to drive down this Virginia pig
path paid pig path and I hate it it's
Aaron not Sparrow Bandera
and if there's any traffic it just makes
me nervous
anyway here we go
[Music]
not doin it
right
oh my gosh
makes fun of me for being on the fire
oh I thought he was talking about money
it's for Jim in my team
taking a picture of
I'm on that column
[Music]
we see it for hey woody 18
having broke
rubber on the rain
they love my rank
when here Wow
when here with my cellphone ring
we're not strangers
anything
[Music]
yeah there we go
well that's around fun most definitely
intended I think I'll go wash my hands
now and if I think about it I'll come
out here and try to clean my steer and
we'll sometime
hey 18 in the books feels good feels
good always feels good to finish one
season and roll right into the next and
that was another amazing fun
[Music]